... Musik...
... Schuss...
So Leute, auf geht's.
Eigener Battlefield 3 Server am Start.
Oh, ich hab' Drop Frames. Was ist da los?
Was ist da los? Warum hab' ich Drop Frames?
... Musik...
Okay, war nur einer.
Baschen, Alter, baschen.
... Musik...
Habt ihr Drop Frames?
In meinem OBS steht, ich hab' Drop Frames.
... Musik...
Aber in meinem Vorschau Stream ist alles gut.
Ich glaub' OBS lügt.
... Musik...
Ehrenloses OBS.
Lull.
... Musik...
Hi Leute.
Hallo Vorazios, Rummanjo.
Der Sebaro ist natürlich auch am Start.
... Musik...
Ist das richtig gewesen?
Bam Bam klatschen muss es.
... Musik...
Keine Notifications.
Komisch, hast du heute Notifications gekriegt?
Hallo CaptainCK.
... Musik...
Sebaro, komm rüber.
Soll ich dich moveen?
... Musik...
Sebaro, ich moved schon mal zu mir.
Gleich mal gucken, wie das Tool funktioniert.
... Musik...
Hat das jetzt geklappt?
Nice.
... Musik...
So, legen wir los.
Musik okay so.
... Musik...
Ich baller mal ein bisschen rum so.
Verhältnis, In-Game Sound, Musik, passt.
Musik lauter, leiser.
... Musik...
Bisschen was rockiges heute.
Passt, nice.
... Musik...
Den Server findet ihr mit Ausrufezeichen Server.
Steht ja auch im Titel drin.
Aber ich wollte es noch mal erwähnen.
... Musik...
Das habe ich eigentlich für Fahrzeug-Parks ausgerüstet.
Warum ist hier alles kaputt?
... Musik...
Und warum verschwinden die Schüsse, wenn man da oben drauf schießt?
Oh, jetzt ist das ganze Haus kaputt.
... Musik...
Jebaited.
Hallo Schniedelwons.
Was ist dein Name?
... Musik...
Tiltfred.
Max Genesis.
... Musik...
Fluxik oder Fluxik.
Je nachdem, wie es richtig ist.
Ach, der Vogelkontakt, ja das ist richtig.
Den habe ich vergessen.
... Musik...
Moment.
Da will mich irgendeiner messern.
Jetzt hat er gedacht, er kann einsteigen.
... Musik...
So einfach ist es aber nicht.
Hallo Twitch Mason.
... Musik...
Oh, ich höre keine Schritte, ich müsste die Musik eigentlich ein bisschen leiser machen.
Ach doch, doch, es geht, es geht.
... Musik...
So, auf Leute, join.
Wenn ihr nicht joint, können wir nicht spielen.
... Musik...
Server Settings sind ziemlich nur nach 15 Standard.
Alle Rushmaps inklusive Back to Karkent.
... Musik...
Also nicht die, nur das erste Addon.
Zack, da hat er mich.
Nur das erste Addon.
... Musik...
Und...
Ja, und ansonsten, halt ziemlich basic, ne.
... Musik...
Einzige, was ich rausgeschmissen habe,...
beziehungsweise...
... Musik...
was der Server-Admin rausgeschmissen hat,...
ist Firestorm.
Ich hasse Firestorm.
... Musik...
Oh, ich habe einen Tonation gekriegt.
Ich nachgucken.
... Musik...
Was ist da los?
Stimmt, dass ich Baro wieder so wie ich den kenne.
... Musik...
Letzter Stream verpasst, feelsBatman.
Aber jetzt für den Battlefield 3 Sauer spenden.
... Musik...
Den Battlefield 3 Sauer habe ich auch nicht selbst bezahlt.
Den hat der Patrick, also TheGame402, bezahlt.
... Musik...
Also der ist schon gesponsert quasi.
Aber Leute, ihr müsst übrigens mal,...
ich habe neue Emotes freigeschaltet.
Ihr müsst LULD, genau, LULD 3D müsst ihr ausprobieren.
So für Battlefield 3.
... Musik...
LULD 3D.
So, und jetzt müssen wir den Server irgendwie voll kriegen.
... Musik...
Wenn das jetzt nicht klappt,...
... dann muss ich das nochmal auf Twitter posten.
... Musik...
Wenn du nur die Schrift siehst und kein Emote,...
... dann musst du bei BetterTwitchTV einstellen,...
... dass du GIF-Emotes anzeigst.
Das ist mittlerweile aus, standardmäßig.
... Musik...
Pff, da ist er.
Hahaha, was ist das?
... Musik...
So, und wie gesagt,...
Joint, was das Zeug hält, sonst können wir nicht anfangen.
... Musik...
Ich poste das nochmal auf Twitter.
Was schreibe ich denn da?
... Musik...
So, Twitter-Message ist raus.
WTF?
Ich kann nicht alles gleichzeitig machen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich kann nicht Panzer fahren, Twitter schreiben und Chat lesen.
Moment, da labert jemand.
Warum labert bei der Musik jemand? Da steht Instrumental drin.
... Musik...
DrLux.
Moin.
... Musik...
So, wir haben echt ein Problem, wenn wir den Server nicht voll kriegen.
Server angelegt, ne?
Was wir in Ruhe spielen können und die ganzen scheiß Cheater-Geschichten von gestern nicht mehr haben.
Aber wenn natürlich keiner draufkommt,...
... dann haben wir ein Problem so.
Also Leute, wenn ihr mitspielen wollt,...
... Ausrufezeichen Server.
... Musik...
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn wir dann die Hälfte oder so, also wenn es losgeht, dann werden wir auch über den Server-Browser welche finden.
Was war denn gestern los? Wir hatten...
... Musik...
Da steht er.
Wir hatten einen sehr skilligen Assault-Rifle-Spieler...
... Musik...
... im Gegner-Team.
Der uns einfach outplayed hat.
Outskilled, outsmarted, outmoved.
Da hat uns einfach outplayed.
Gestern, der Typ.
... Musik...
Wir müssen nur den Sauerfall kriegen.
Also wir brauchen zumindest noch fünf Spieler, dass wir die Runde anfangen können.
... Musik...
Ich habe extra gestern gefragt, wer alles Battlefield 3 hat.
Das waren ganz viele, das wollten ganz viele mitspielen.
Aber wie das halt immer so ist...
... zwischen denen, die schreiben und zwischen denen, die dann wirklich kommen, ist halt immer noch ein Unterschied.
Aber wir warten noch kurz.
Haben wir Zeit.
Hallo, Kia3.
... Musik...
Doch, gestern war ganz schlimm.
Gestern war nicht nur ein Cheater.
Aber mittlerweile interessiert sich halt DICE auch absolut nicht mehr.
Sahen die Beete hier schon immer so hässlich leer aus.
Aber mittlerweile interessiert sich halt auch DICE absolut null für Battlefield 3.
... Musik...
Auf geht's Leute.
Server joinen.
Go, go.
Ich ändere nochmal die Message von dem Server.
Dann nochmal Nightbot.
... Musik...
Nightbot.
Enden wir die Message mal ein bisschen ab.
... Musik...
Also Fluxik, gestern war Cheater verseucht ohne Ende.
Richtig Cheater verseucht.
... Musik...
So, Commands.
Custom.
... Musik...
Hab mich immer wieder diese UIs designt.
Da ist ja Ausrufzeichen Server edit.
... Musik...
Drei Server, zack.
Submit.
... Musik...
Was geht eigentlich mit dem Schatten von dem Baum gerade ab?
Das ist auch nicht normal.
... Musik...
To play on a server with Back to Karkent.
Ach, es gibt Leute die Back to Karkent nicht haben.
... Musik...
Kann ich rausnehmen.
Dann nehme ich Karkent raus.
... Musik...
Ich dachte Karkent hat quasi jeder, weil es bei Battlefield 3 dabei war.
Kann es trotzdem nicht joinen, was sagt er denn?
... Musik...
So eigentlich sollte das gehen.
Ich bin selbst mit dem gleichen Link gejoint.
... Musik...
Ihr könnt kein Battlefield 3 Server joinen, das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Ähm...
Romantisch glaube ich nicht, dass das absichtlich ist.
... Musik...
Die haben einfach den Support eingestellt, die haben keinen Bock mehr in dem Game was zu machen.
Okay, ich mache einfach mal Back to Karkent aus.
... Musik...
Wenn ich jetzt noch finden würde wie das funktioniert.
Server Settings hier.
... Musik...
Map Rotation.
Kann ich die Map Rotation überhaupt einstellen?
Ich war schon ewig nicht mehr in diesem Procon Tool unterwegs.
... Musik...
Rush Grandpa Zarya, das ist richtig.
Also ich mache Karkent, mache ich jetzt raus, wenn ich gefunden habe wo das geht.
Hier List, Map List.
... Musik...
Strike at Karkent, jawoll.
Raus damit.
... Musik...
Ups.
Na toll.
Jetzt habe ich die Map nicht rausgeschmissen, sondern habe sie eingeschaltet.
Da muss ich die jetzt noch mal rauswerfen.
... Musik...
Schlecht.
Aber jetzt habe ich die Map rausgeschmissen.
... Musik...
Und jetzt switchen wir wieder um auf Grand Bazaar.
Das nehme ich die erste Map in der Rotation.
Und nun sollte eigentlich der Server keinen Back to Karkent mehr voraussetzen.
... Musik...
Macht er auch nicht.
Also ihr solltet jetzt joinen können.
... Musik...
Könnt ihr mal ausprobieren, solltet ihr jetzt gehen.
Der Stream pixeliert bei mir ganz schön.
Das baue ich auch so.
... Musik...
So pixelig.
Aber OBS hängt hier bei 6 MBit.
... Musik...
Mehr geht nicht.
Ja, mehr kann ich nicht machen.
... Musik...
Hallo, kleiner Rax.
Ich habe sogar noch Battlefield 3.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar noch Battlefield 3 Keys.
... Musik...
Gab es Battlefield 3 nicht letztens umsonst?
Oder beziehungsweise ist Battlefield 3 nicht sogar noch umsonst?
... Musik...
Nee, das war Quatsch, vergiss es, das war Bad Company 2.
Das war Bad Company 2, was umsonst war.
... Musik...
Hinter mir rennt er.
Ha!
Schreckt.
Oh, Runde startet.
Jetzt geht los.
... Musik...
Ja, Bingo Less Than 3.
Dann scheint deine Platte ein bisschen lah zu sein.
... Musik...
Aber es stand in der Server Message schon, du hast gejoint.
Also prinzipiell sollte es funktionieren.
... Musik...
Übrigens, der Bot müsste eigentlich den Server automatisch alle 5 Minuten posten.
Macht er das denn?
... Musik...
Ich guck mal.
In your face.
... Musik...
Postet der Bot das denn jetzt?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Timer.
... Musik...
Server, Timer alle 5 Minuten ist enabled.
Also sollte der Bot posten.
... Musik...
Ja, Ausrufzeichen Server geht natürlich auch.
Ja, Ausrufzeichen Server.
... Musik...
Oh, ich werde gerätzt.
Moment, warum hat das dem gerade keinen Damage gemacht?
... Musik...
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Headbang Time.
... Musik...
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt... Ach, Spawn Schutz.
Stimmt, das gab es ja auch noch.
... Musik...
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mal ein Delay einstellen.
Das könnte man ziemlich krass streng snipen.
... Musik...
Was sagt?
Das sind aber halt Gegner, die können spielen.
Das sind halt nicht so die 0815 Random-Bobs.
Das merkste gleich.
... Musik...
Wat?
Rättsplitz.
... Musik...
Shit.
Kriegst du schon Rätts?
... Musik...
Scheiße.
Ein bisschen mehr Leute brauchen wir noch.
Steht der Server in...
Kann mal jemand gucken, ob der Server im Server-Browser ordentlich drin steht?
... Musik...
Also ob man den auch findet?
Okay.
... Musik...
Weil ich hoffe mal, dass wir auch ein paar Spieler über den Server-Browser kriegen.
Ja Bingo, das macht nichts.
... Musik...
Wenn es gar so einseitig ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir irgendwie einen Balance-Plugin drin?
... Musik...
Ich denke mal nicht.
Aber können wir dann machen.
... Musik...
Wat?
Wie ging das jetzt?
... Musik...
Bist du schon Rätts?
Scheiße.
... Musik...
Ja Sniper-Limit ist wichtig.
Sniper-Limit brauchen wir.
Ohne Sniper-Limit geht nicht.
... Musik...
Man sieht nichts.
Weil das Gegner-Team scheint mir dezent besser zu sein.
... Musik...
Oh, Ausrufezeichen, Sniper. Auch das ist schön.
Sniper-Limit ist das Wichtigste überhaupt.
... Musik...
Ohne Sniper-Limit geht nichts.
Braucht man.
... Musik...
Nope, so nicht.
Schön in die Ecke stellen.
... Musik...
Ja, macht mal schön euer...
Gucken, dass da von der Seite keiner kommt.
... Musik...
Komm Leute, rein, rein, rein, rein.
Rein, rein, alles wegsprayen, wegsprayen und retzen.
... Musik...
Kommt von hinten gleich einer.
Oder auch nicht.
... Musik...
Ich erwarte, dass da gleich von hinten einer kommt.
Ah, da ist ja noch einer. Direkt vor der Tür.
... Musik...
Also ich finde die Base ist ziemlich schwer.
Ist einer der schwersten Base, also einer der schwersten...
... Musik...
Fuck.
Einer der schwersten M-Coms finde ich im ganzen Game.
... Musik...
Das hier in Bazaar.
Hat das Stream bei euch 60 FPS?
... Musik...
Sollte 720p 60 FPS sein.
Einmal hingelegt.
... Musik...
Jetzt müssen wir das nur noch ordentlich defenden.
Normalerweise sollten wir auch ein Panzer hier kriegen.
... Musik...
Okay, nice.
Ja, wenn Twitch das sagt, 760, dann ist gut.
... Musik...
Was? Wo kommt der her?
So, ich hoffe wir kriegen ordentlich viele Spieler, wenn wir da ein bisschen höher im Server Browser stehen.
... Musik...
Was? Wir sind dritter im Server Browser.
Komm Leute, spawn rein.
... Musik...
Okay, nice.
Linke Seite, linke Seite ist einer.
... Musik...
Ich wusste, dass du um die Ecke kommst. So einfach ist es nicht hier.
Fuck von der Seite.
... Musik...
Der Panzer muss die weg machen.
Ich finde die letzte Base ist auch ziemlich schwer.
... Musik...
Echt war Karkent nie free?
Ich hatte das beim Kauf mit dabei.
... Musik...
Weil ich habe auch keine Allerweiterung hier.
Das war mir dabei beim Game.
... Musik...
Das hatte ich sogar auf der Xbox dabei.
Wie gesagt, das hatte ich sogar auf der Xbox dabei.
... Musik...
Oh, die sind auf der Hauptstraße.
Da kommt gleich hier was lang.
... Musik...
Moment, was? Warum stirbt ihr da?
Ihr werdet nicht gestorben.
... Musik...
Aber jetzt geht es doch schon. Jetzt kann man Spieler.
Erzhammerspieler.
... Musik...
Ich retz den Typ mal.
Oh, der hat mich schon geretzt.
... Musik...
Komm raus. Kopf raus.
Spielt ja Ka-Boom eigentlich noch.
Ich glaube, das letzte Battlefield, was er gespielt hat, war Battlefield 1.
Battlefield 1 hat er sich auch gekauft, hat er erzählt, ja.
... Musik...
Aber ich glaube, so wirklich aktiv spielt er nicht mehr.
Aber wenn wir futtern gehen, so viel kann ich euch verraten.
... Musik...
So richtig abgeschlossen mit YouTube hat er noch nicht.
Er überlegt sich immer noch ab und zu, soll ich was hochladen, soll ich nichts hochladen.
... Musik...
Und YouTube ist natürlich immer noch Thema, auch Jahre jetzt hier, schon danach quasi.
Ich retz den mal schnell.
... Musik...
Wenn wir was futtern gehen.
Wo bist du, Kollege?
... Musik...
Man darf nicht retzen.
Weshalb auch immer.
... Musik...
Rekt.
Fuck, da stand er in der Ecke.
Scheiße, den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Er stand ja auch so versteckt.
... Musik...
Ich glaube, so einfach ins Stream holen lässt er sich jetzt nicht.
Okay, den sollten wir aber haben, B.
... Musik...
Was haben wir als nächstes für eine Map?
Ich hoffe ja, das neue Battlefield wird entweder in Bad Company 3.
... Musik...
So im Geiste von Bad Company 3.
Also ne, so im Geiste von Bad Company.
... Musik...
Oder sowas wie Battlefield 3.
Einfach mal wieder ein Game, was nicht einfach nur am Anfang gehypt ist.
Und man es am Anfang vielleicht auch kurz geil findet, aber danach schnell wieder verfliegt.
Sondern ein Game wie Battlefield 3, was man auch zwei Jahre oder so spielen kann.
... Musik...
Gibt es eigentlich schon Infos?
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Battlefield 2018.
Gab es da jetzt irgendwas Neues zu?
... Musik...
Gab es da ein Trailer oder so?
Trailer?
... Musik...
Battlefield 2018 Trailer?
Ne.
... Musik...
Nicht wirklich.
Kein Trailer.
... Musik...
Vielleicht schaffen sie es ja dieses Mal wieder, einen ordentlichen Battlefield-Soundtrack zu machen.
Wobei das ist in Battlefield 1 ja auch schon wieder gut.
Das war nur in Battlefield 3 und 4 hier.
... Musik...
Wo man sich gedacht hat, da hat irgendwie einer zum ersten Mal so eine Audioeffekt-Workstation entdeckt.
Flankerino.
... Musik...
Der ist dauernd.
Stopp wir brauchen, Leute, geht mal an B.
... Musik...
Wisst ihr, ich sag keine an B.
Hat jemand das Game schon mal gespielt?
... Musik...
Fuck, ich dachte, ich mach jetzt 900 EQ-Play.
Ich lass den Typ nochmal, ich lass den Typ nochmal.
Also mein Plan war jetzt ja, ich retz den, der wird gekillt.
Und dann hör ich drauf, wenn die Leute nachladen und dann renn ich rein.
... Musik...
Das war mein geplanter 900 EQ-Play, aber der hat leider nicht geklappt.
So und falls ihr jetzt da rüber flanken wollt, mach ich euch platt.
... Musik...
Aber ihr könnt auch genau, ihr könnt nämlich auch einfach durchlaufen.
Rekt.
... Musik...
Da steht er.
Oh nice, thank you Rats.
... Musik...
Wir müssen jetzt, wie jetzt alle hier rumhampeln, anstatt zu...
Oh, 3 Milliarden Gegner vorm...
Eieiei...
3 Milliarden Gegner vorm mkomm.
... Musik...
Headbang-Time.
Was haben wir denn überhaupt für Perks?
Was haben wir denn überhaupt für Perks? Squad Covers, Squad Dings, Squad Ammo haben wir auch.
Ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Jetzt wird der Server langsam voll. Jawoll!
Voll berg!
Gucken wir mal, ob wir hier ein bisschen Leute abfahren können.
Oh!
Fritz, aber was macht der da bitte schön?
Panzer?
Hopp!
Oh! Der Panzer wills wissen!
Nice!
Achtung!
Oh!
Nice!
Achtung, Achtung! Panzer, Panzer!
Oh!
Lol!
Wir müssen da raus! Wir haben nichts gegen den Panzer!
Wir haben nichts gegen den Panzer, ich renn da jetzt raus. Ich bin auch im Spawn-Schutz.
Hartmann hat mich getroffen.
Das war keine so taktisch geschickte Idee sich da in die Ecke zu stellen, ne?
Wait, what? Das Ammo kommt hier schon weg? Ach fuck, wir sind ja noch in der Base vorher.
Alter, wie der letzte Kack nupt er.
Ich muss das defenden.
Oh!
Wie der letzte Kack nupt er. Ich muss das defenden.
Jetzt muss ich weg, weil von der Mitte kann man nicht defenden. Man kann nur hinter dem Stein hier ganz gut defenden. Rest sackt.
Ja, dem Stein ist ok.
Ok. Wir brauchen was gegen den Panzer.
Ach, warum kommt denn jetzt hier keiner? Als wenn ich mich schonmal hier ordentlich platziert hab.
Ich geh mal vor.
What?
Einfach auf die Ecke gelaufen direkt.
Oh, war das knapp.
Erwischt. Fuck, Panzer. Das ist jetzt kacke mit dem Panzer hier.
Ich weiß ja nicht wo das steckt. Wir müssen die Panzer killen. Es hat keinen Sinn wenn wir da krasse Assault-Flank-Action machen.
Dann muss der Panzer out. Guckt euch das mal an, der Panzer-Typ, der reckt uns alle.
Erwischt. Ok, mal gucken, hier kommt bestimmt gleich einer. Waren hier schon alle wählen heute? Guck mal, Frage in die Runde.
Lol, das hat er sich anders vorgestellt.
Das hier ist schwer einzunehmen.
Die müssen geschreckt werden, die Typen. Was? TF?
Oh, da wurde gerätzt, der Typ. Oder auch nicht. Ich war auch wählen, kurz bevor ich im Streben war. Quasi 2 Sekunden bevor ich Streben angemacht hab, bin ich heimgekommen.
Spielst du eher so Def oder Acro? Kommt darauf an wie die Runde läuft. Manchmal mach ich halt Yolo reinrennen.
Oh, oh, oh, fuck. Oh nice, nice, nice. Kriegen wir, kriegen wir.
Der nicht legt sich hin. Warum legt der nicht nicht hin? Alter, wie er sich nicht hingelegt hat, sonst hätt ich überlebt. Fuck.
Meinst du ich mich? Aber trotzdem keine schlechte Frage.
Ich hab schon mal drauf Antworten. Ich finde das sieht man in allen Games, also nicht nur Battlefield, zwar durch die, krasser Killtrade, durch die Bankweg in allen Games, ähm, richtig gute Spieler.
Wissen, wann sie aggressiv sein. Also ich sag jetzt nicht, dass ich das in Battlefield immer hin bekomme, aber man kann das beobachten, auch in Overwatch. Gute Spieler wissen, wann sie quasi hinten bleiben müssen und wann sie jetzt aggressiv werden können.
Es hat keinen Sinn sinnlos aggressiv zu sein, reinzurennen, sondern du musst die Gelegenheit abwarten und dann richtig, und dann nicht das wie viele Loops machen, das sind die Games so nach dem Motto, ha, so, ich hab jetzt 3 Gegner gekillt, hm, kann ich jetzt vor, kann ich jetzt vor, ja, gehen wir mal vor, tot.
Du musst sagen, so nach dem Motto, bam, gebashed, jetzt vor. Nicht, nicht ne halbe Stunde überlegen, das machen Loops. Die richtig guten Leute, die wissen, zack, zack, zack, jetzt ist gute Gelegenheit, jetzt drauf.
Das sieht man in Overwatch, richtig gut, wenn man sich mal die Pros anguckt, da wird nicht sinnlos, sinnlos reingedivet oder fuck, oder sinnlos irgendwie gebashed, äh, sinnlos versucht reinzurennen oder sowas.
Da gehts rein, sobald man Vorteil hat, und dann richtig, und dann wird nicht rumgehampelt ne halbe Stunde, bis dann wieder quasi die Gegner respawn sind, sondern dann gehts rein. Sobald es heißt rein, dann gehts rein mit allen Mann.
So muss er das machen. Also die Kunst ist eigentlich zu wissen, wann man aggressiv sein muss. Also nicht so hier hin und her rennen wie ich das gerade war.
Was? Also manchmal, der Netcode, den versteh ich manchmal nicht.
Wenn man Vorteile hat einfach rein, genauso ist es Patrick, genauso ist es.
So ist es. So und nicht anders. Wenn man Vorteile hat, muss man rein.
Ich muss zurück.
Spawnshots?
Null.
Null 3D.
Was? Alter wo? Wo? Hä? Wo kam der denn bitte her?
Das war null 4D.
Null, null, hyper null.
Aber so ist es, so ist es echt hier in dem Game, wenn man Vorteile hat drauf, dann nicht ewig rumrennen und gucken und machen und tun, sondern drauf.
Und dann, wenn man noch zielen kann, dann ist es nur noch am allerbesten.
So und jetzt müssen wir drauf. Jetzt bleibt nichts als übrig, wir haben was gekillt, es sieht clear aus. Jetzt hat es keinen Sinn mal hier ewig rumzuhampeln.
Was labert eigentlich der Musikstream da immer so rum?
Boah, der Panzerfahrer ist nicht schlecht.
It's the real Pants man.
Ähm, was?
Was sagst du dazu, dass Master Scorpion den Schultz interviewen durfte? Ich muss ja sagen, ich fand die Wahl sehr überfraglich.
Naja, also wenn ich mir überlege, welche Leute das eingefädelt haben, dann schickt man halt auch die Leute hin mit der größten Fanbase.
Nicht unbedingt die, die vielleicht die cleversten Fragen stellen können. Ich hab jetzt das von Marcel direkt nicht gesehen.
Aber ich denke mal, hat er sich Mühe gegeben? Was hat er gefragt? Ich weiß es nicht. Weiß jemand, was er gefragt hat?
Also ich hätte ihn gefragt, ob er weiß, was ein 260 Quickscope ist.
Wenn er es nicht gewusst hätte, hätte ich gesagt, LOL NOB.
Haha, dumm. Da warst du nicht der einzige.
Hallo Zirin. Ah, Terran Highway, nice map.
Am besten fand ich, am besten fand ich, ähm, wo die Merkel interviewt wurde von, ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht wer das war.
Wo die dann gemeint hat, ja, das war jetzt mein erstes Interview.
Und wo dann die Merkel gesagt hat, ja und, was machen sie sonst? Sonst nur Selbstdarstellung oder was?
Richtig burnt, richtig burnt.
Obwohl das gar nicht war, die Absicht von ihr war wahrscheinlich.
Das hat es aber genau getroffen, ja und was machen sie sonst? Sonst nur Selbstdarstellung oder was?
Das war nice. Alter, was mache ich hier gerade? Und vor allem, was macht die Fahrzeugphysik?
Und ich will nicht, dass der Panzer, 1A Fahrer, ja so sieht es aus.
Ein nicer Fahrer bin ich. Sieht man ja.
Bliat, Bliat.
Was?
Was ist denn da jetzt verreckt?
Was? Warum ist er nicht gestorben? Will der mich rollen oder was?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen oder was? Warum seid ihr nicht gestorben? Was ist denn hier los?
Wir brauchen übrigens Engineers, ne? Nur so, angemerkt.
Achtung, Achtung jetzt. Jetzt, jetzt schreckt. Nein, nein, nein. Ach man, ich wollte es krass im Flank machen.
Externes Audio Interface ist das Beste.
Also für alle, die nicht so eine, weil ich halt die Diskussion sehe im Chat über irgendwie Soundkarten und sowas,
wenn man nicht irgendwelche Super Gaming Features braucht von seiner Soundkarte,
also sprich, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie so Surround Sound Berechnung oder so komische Dinge haben möchte von seiner Soundkarte,
ist das Beste entweder man hat eine Onboard Soundkarte mit einem optischen Ausgang
und kann das an ordentlichen Receiver anschließen, Anlage, was auch immer, wo man dann seinen Kopfhörer anschließt,
oder man holt sich ein Audio Interface.
Sowas quasi, was für Heimstudios gedacht ist oder für Musiker oder so, mit Mikrofonanschluss, Kopfhörerausgang und sowas.
Da gibt es auch günstige, also irgendwie so 100 Euro oder so oder noch günstiger.
Und nachdem die ja auch quasi zum Aufzeichnen von Gesang, Instrument und sonst was gedacht sind
und natürlich dementsprechend auch zum ordentlichen, what the fuck, zum ordentlichen Anhören dabei, ist die Soundqualität das Beste.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Ich muss raus.
Jetzt schreckt.
Und hinter mir ist was.
Rekt.
Die spawnen hier hinten, kann das sein?
Objective has been neutralized.
Nein, fürs Mod-Mick lohnt sich das nicht, da hat der Game Recht.
Also wenn man ein Mikrofon anschließen will und ein besseres hat,
die meisten Audio Interfaces bzw. alle Audio Interfaces, die für sowas gedacht sind, haben einen XLR-Eingang.
Fürs Mod-Mick lohnt sich das nicht wirklich.
Was man als Kompromiss machen kann ist, man kann sich so ein kleines für den Tisch kaufen.
Also sowas, so ein Mixer Audio Interface in einem.
Da gibt es von Yamaha was, spricht man die überhaupt so aus? Yamaha, Yamaha spricht man die aus, ne?
Gibt so ein kleines, kostet 120 Euro, da ist quasi ein Mixer mit dabei,
hat einen Anschluss für die normalen 3,5mm Kopfhörer, äh, Schwachsinn Mikrofone,
also sprich auch mit der Stromversorgung, die diese Mikrofone brauchen.
Und von Berrien gibt es eins, wobei ich das von Yamaha besser finde.
Yamaha besser finde.
Yamaha!
Ich glaube der ganze Surfer hat es auf mich abgesehen gerade.
Cool.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so gute Musik hörst, Max, das ist eine Heavy Metal Instrumental Playlist auf YouTube.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Zebaro ist die Legehänne.
Ja, mach mal weiter Legehänne.
Oh oh oh. Ich muss hier weg, der Panzer, der hat, der guckt auf mich drauf.
Wow. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das hier überlebe gerade, um ehrlich zu sein.
Da ist ja noch einer. Oh, wir haben es, nice.
Der kommt hier rum.
Schreckt!
Guck mal, ob sich der eine dahinter versteckt.
Nee, macht er nicht.
Cebaro ist aber eine richtige Legehänne hier, wenn ich mir die Stats so angucke.
3-1 und Erster, das kann nur Legehännen-Status bedeuten.
Mein Nachbar hat sich Hühner gekauft, fällt mir gerade so ein.
Zum Thema Legehänne.
Das sind riesen Dinger, ey.
Ist gar nicht, dass es so große Hühnern gibt.
Könnte ich quasi in den Garten gehen, um der Legehänne beim Legen zu gucken.
Uwe!
Nein!
Uwe! Nein! Ich wollte jetzt über die...
Moment, warum sterbt ihr hier alle gerade?
Weil dein Nehmer uns einen Typ stellt.
Warum sterbt ihr alle?
Wollt ihr mir Rätspunkte geben, ha?
Gebt's zu.
Ihr wollt mir Rätspunkte geben.
Oh, fuck.
Duck ist ein digital analog Konverter.
Also das, was im Endeffekt aus dem Sound von deinem Computer Sound macht, den du halt ausgeben kannst.
Leider sind unsere Ohren halt analog.
Wenn unsere Ohren nicht analog wären, dann hätten wir die ganzen Probleme nicht.
Drehen sie aber auf, die Jäger.
Ich leb auch noch Red... Red... Was?
Red Eier.
Können wir jetzt hier mal durch? Ich... Yolo, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo.
Ey, ich will hier...
Warum kann... Warum kann man hier nicht drüber?
Dice, please!
So.
Ich hab Schiss vor dem Panzer.
Haben wir irgendwas, um das hier kaputt zu machen?
Okay. Man kann's ja mal probieren.
Ein digital analog Konverter.
Ist das.
Also quasi das, was deine Onward Soundkarte auch macht.
Den Sound vom Rechner nehmen und in, ähm, halt...
Strom...
Zeug umwandeln, was du dann...
Über Kopfhörer ausgeben kannst.
Go, go, go.
Baschen, alter, baschen.
Ah!
Wo... Wo...
Die sind einfach aufgetaucht vor mir.
Einfach aufgetaucht, so.
So.
Get wrecked.
Oh, weggesprayed, richtig krass weggesprayed.
Alter, weggsprayer.
Moment, das ist ja schon weg hier.
Zack.
Da vorne ist noch einer.
Das... Wie überleb ich das hier eigentlich gerade?
Gibt eigentlich nix, wie ich das überleben dürfte.
Oh, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer.
Läuft ganz gut.
Und es sind wenigstens keine Gegner, wo man einfach komplett rüberrutscht.
Moment, wo rennt?
Unten ist er.
Hier unten ist er.
Er hat jetzt gebashed.
Da ist er.
In der Hecke, im Busch liegt er.
Busch Camper.
Scheiße, zu spät.
Weiter geht's.
Spielst du noch CSGO?
Nee.
Kein CSGO mehr.
Ich war's nicht, CMD Bingo.
Ich war's nicht.
Ich hab's da drauf geschossen.
Ich wär's gern gewesen, aber ich war's nicht.
Ja.
Ja, Sebaro, geb ich dir recht.
Das Spiel macht richtig Bock.
Ist einfach ein geiles Game.
Da macht's jetzt auch nicht aus, dass es...
Fuck.
...dass es ein bisschen älter ist.
Ja, kommst rein.
Ist das jeder Battlefield?
Komm auf den Server drauf.
Yolo.
Nichts Yolo.
Welche Specs hat dein PC zurzeit?
Mach mal...
Hm.
Das gab ein Chat-Kommando dafür.
Oh, versuch mal Ausrufezeichen, PC, Ausrufezeichen, Speck oder so.
Ah, nice, nice.
Alter.
Lol.
War das...
Wo ist der Typ?
Wenn man das Ding hier auf der Seite hat, ist das...
Wenn man das Ding spielen kann, ne?
Und einen ordentlichen Fahrer hat und einem Team was anrepariert.
Das ist das Geilste ever.
Der Amtrak.
Der Amtrak, das ist das Geilste ever, das Ding.
Das Ding haut so krass rein.
Das Ding haut so übertrieben rein, der Amtrak.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt euch das mal an, das ist doch nicht normal.
Lol.
Problem ist, wir müssten halt mal vorwärts fahren, ne?
Fahrt mich halt mal einer weg.
Fahrt mich doch mal einer weg, please.
Jetzt aber, jetzt werden sie gebashed.
Rekt.
Wo sind sie?
Da könnt ihr mal gar nichts dagegen machen, liebe Gegner.
Paz.
Oh fuck, raus, raus, raus, zu spät.
30-6-0, der Amtrak, das Ding ist so OP.
0-3-D.
Ich mag den Xbox One Controller nicht.
Der Xbox One Controller wurde als eines der besten Neuerungen gelobt von der Xbox.
Von der Xbox One.
Aber für mich ist der 360 Controller immer noch der beste.
Was, Hacker? Wer hackt denn?
Wer hackt?
Ich hab jetzt noch keinen gesehen, der hackt.
Wenn einer hackt, wird er gebannt.
Ganz einfach.
Ich hab hier extra schon die Konsole offen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Einfach ein Bannhammer.
Klatschen muss es dann.
Bam, ba ba bam.
Also mir gefällt der 360 Controller besser, flocksig.
Der Media Markt wird bestimmt beide Controller haben.
Der hat eher Xbox One Controller als 360 Controller.
Aber der hat bestimmt beides.
Wie einfach bei dir und Eax die gleiche Musik läuft, ernsthaft?
Kannst du mir mal schreiben?
Ja, ja.
Patrick, das wär nice.
Mit Bundliste.
Dass uns Spasten wie der Typ gestern gar nicht erst ins Game kommen.
Wie oft war es bei Maxi, wie oft zu Eustro?
Gar nicht.
Das letzte Mal besoffen war ich, da hab ich noch TV-Links gemacht.
Wobei, stimmt das?
Also so richtig.
Stimmt das überhaupt?
Lass mal überlegen.
So, das letzte Mal, das Silvester, das zählt nicht.
Da war ich ja nie so komplett im Arsch.
Ja, ich glaub, das letzte Mal so richtig besoffen war ich, wo ich noch TV-Links gemacht hab.
Also könnt ihr euch überlegen, wie lang das her ist.
Sonst gibt's ja heut gar nicht mehr.
Oh, damit gebashed.
Bam!
Richtig schön erwischt, den Tank.
Der will aber hier in Haupteingang, da müssen wir rüberfahren.
Erwischt.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, alter.
Der will mich flanken.
Flank, flank, Reno-Tank.
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, wo er hin ist.
Schreck, Moment.
Schreckt.
Den Panzer holen wir uns.
Go, go.
Ich hab Gas.
Boah!
Ich brauch einen rappen.
Okay, gebashed.
Moment, wie kriegen die das?
Wir haben alles gebashed von den Gegnern.
Ah nein, wir haben's diffused.
Watt, watt, watt.
Das kann doch nicht sein, wir haben die Gegner nicht.
Das kann doch nicht sein, wir haben die bitte angelegt.
Ich mach jetzt Yolo-Diffuse.
Nice.
Der ist bestimmt oben, der Typ.
Ich komm mit rauf.
Jawoll, wusste, dass du oben bist, Kollege.
So einfach geht's hier aber nicht.
Da hinten, hinter uns.
Oh, der klaut den Panzer, fuck.
Die Noobs fahren den Panzer.
Ich hol jetzt den anderen Panzer.
Moment, kann man...
Ah, hier fehlt die Leiter.
Alter, jetzt will keiner Panzer fahren, ne?
Dann mach ich jetzt hier mal den Yolo-Run zum Panzer,
dass er uns nicht auch noch geklaut wird.
Watt, zappert, das gibt's doch nicht.
Was ist denn die Gegner?
Sag mal, ich bin immer mitten in meiner Base,
werde ich gerabt.
Ich muss hier weg.
Okay, der andere sollte es aber auch verrecken.
Ich guck gleich in den Chat, ich kann grad nicht,
ist zu anstrengend.
Moment, hier ist ja gar keine Wand mehr drin.
Alter, was soll das?
Wo ist die Wand hin?
Der Amtrak da hinten macht mir ein bisschen Angst,
wenn er auf mich schießt.
Okay, der sieht mich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das hier kann man nicht einschließen,
oder?
Ich hau ab.
Was?
Gerade, wo ich raushüpfen wollte.
Ja, Panzer, Server läuft gut.
Was, was, was, was?
Oh, meine Güte.
Ich blicke da immer durch,
wirklich total chaotisch gerade von allen Seiten.
Entrix, magst du mir deine Meinung
über Visual Studio verraten?
Meinst du das richtig, das große Visual Studio,
oder meinst du Code?
Wenn du es einfach so schreibst,
würde ich jetzt vom Großen ausgehen.
Alter, was ist denn hier los gerade?
Wir müssen mal die Gegner weiten
und ein bisschen rauspushen.
Die komplette Entwicklungsumgebung, finde ich gut.
Oh Mann, hier geht da nichts gerade.
Der Amtrak, der muss einfach mal sterben.
Die legen jetzt übrigens.
Legehennen machen sie.
Ach nee, machen keine Legehennen.
Die Entwicklungsumgebung, ja, ich glaube,
ich gehe mal davon aus,
du meinst das große Visual Studio,
finde ich richtig gut.
Eines der besten Sachen,
die Microsoft hier zustande gebracht hat.
Ich finde, das stinkt gegen
die meisten anderen Entwicklungsumgebungen ab.
Visual Studio ist in Maßen,
also für eine Idee, relativ schnell.
Hat standardmäßig ein ziemlich gutes Feature Set.
Du kannst alles damit machen.
Es ist simpel einzurichten.
Wie lange gibt es da in Battlefield 3?
Schon seit heute Morgen, nee, seit gestern Abend.
Der Chefs.
Ich lasse den Server auch offen.
Ja, der Cam, der Cute Creator,
den finde ich auch richtig gut.
Also für C++.
Ist mir auch am liebsten.
C++ mag ich Visual Studio nicht so.
Oh, Eclipse.
Nee, Eclipse komm ich gar nicht klar.
Eclipse ist das aufgepläteste,
am eklig zu bedienende Ding, was ich kenne.
Ich benutze Visual Studio, Cute Creator
oder wenn es Kommandozeile wimm.
Ich will als Assault spawnen.
Und Visual Studio Code
für Kleinkram unter Windows.
Teufelweiche, Eclipse ist das Schlimmste.
Eclipse mag ich gar nicht.
Ich meine jedem das Seine.
Eclipse ist bestimmt
für Java basierte Sachen nicht schlecht.
Also man kann damit mit Sicherheit arbeiten.
Aber ich krieg Zustände, wenn ich Eclipse verwenden muss.
Dann lieber IntelliJ,
wenn es Java, Groovy oder sonst was in der Richtung sein muss.
Du findest die Ideen von JetBrains besser.
Hast du schon mal Rider ausprobiert?
Gerade dabei sind,
das ist die neue C-Sharp-Idee von JetBrains.
Also da finde ich Visual Studio schon schöner.
Aber ansonsten sind die JetBrains Sachen echt gut.
Ich habe früher viel ReSharper verwendet.
Das einzige was mich da gestört hat,
ist wenn es ein bisschen mehr ist,
wenn es ein bisschen größer geworden ist
oder wenn man halt nicht so ordentlich war
und direkt gehaun hat und so.
Dann hat es Visual Studio schon ziemlich langsam gemacht.
Was ist das?
Ja, Yolo Run durch die Gegner spawnen.
Wo stellt man sich hier am besten hin?
Ich hab das voll vergessen.
Die Gegner spawnen ja hinter mir.
Die Sache ist die, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht hinten, sondern vorne.
Da ist schon der erste.
Der defuseder Typ.
Defused?
Der defused gar nicht.
Easy, easy life.
Ich hab nichts gesehen durch den Zaun.
Das gefällt mir übrigens auch im Battlefield 3 richtig gut,
dass man die ganzen geilen Schnipser
durch das Reflektieren vom Zielfernrohr sieht.
Oder alles mit einem Scope halt.
Ihr wollt flenken, ihr wollt hier rum flenken.
Ich wusste, warum stirbst du nicht, Alter?
Alter lahm.
Lass mich mitfahren.
Oh, bist schon voll.
Der hat ja nämlich einen eingerichteten Server.
Ich kann dir das gar nicht sagen.
Aber der Server ist soweit, ich weiß, ziemlich roh konfiguriert zur Zeit.
Aber dann Bun plugin kam, glaube ich, als letztes noch drauf.
Oh, fuck, Jett.
Ah, scheiße, wenn man jetzt noch ordentlich aimen könnte.
Wieso ist das Müll, Fluxik?
Bann das Leute, die man eigentlich nicht bannen will?
Auflockt sich, naja.
Aber für dich können wir bestimmt einen White-Lester-Eintrag machen oder so.
Boi, Phil.
Also, falls du von Appleboy redest, redest dann sauer.
Guck mal, Leute.
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht, wie man hier ordentlich fährt.
Also, wo lang, dass ich nicht weiß, wie man ordentlich fährt, habt ihr gerade alle gesehen.
Ach guck mal, wir haben Rambo im Team, bestimmt der echte.
Und morgen schon Commander Krieger angezeigt.
Ah ne, das war umgedreht, ganz vergessen.
Das war ja umgedreht.
Anzeige ist raus.
Warum ist denn ich gestorben durch den Hit gerade?
What the fuck?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, der will uns bashen, der Typ.
Ich muss weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Ja.
Scheiße.
Ich dachte, ich kann auch drunter durchfahren.
Jets sind echt der opäste Shit, weil man einen guten Jetpilot als Gegner hat in dem Game, das gibt.
Der Sebaro macht das schon, der Sebaro ist richtige Legehennen.
Richtig Legehennen ist es.
Richtig Legehennen.
Bam.
Jolo, Chat, Snipe Versuch.
Warum nur 720p, weil man als Nicht-Twitch-Partner nur 6 Mbit Upload hat.
Und 1080p 60fps sieht reudig aus mit 6 Mbit Upload.
Vor allem, wenn man es dann noch über die Grafikkarte entkonen lässt, was prinzipiell schon mal eine schlechtere Quali hat.
Ich hab NTP gewählt.
Das war jetzt ein ganz schlechter Witz, ich weiß.
Wahrscheinlich hat ihr noch nicht mal jemand verstanden, bis auf 3-4.
Soll ich sagen, was ich gewählt hab?
Also ich sag da normalerweise nicht gerne was zu, weil ich niemand beeinflussen will.
Aber ich kanns euch sagen, weil das eigentlich gar keinen wirklich beeinflussen kann.
Ja, ernsthaft jetzt.
Also ich war schon, ich war schon gewählt.
Ich kanns euch, ich werd's euch erzählen.
Ich werd's euch erzählen.
Und zwar hab ich ungültig gewählt.
Bashen, bashen, alter, bashen.
Ich muss den Chat auen.
Chat, Chat, wo ist er?
Wo ist er?
Alter, wo ist er?
Nice, er ist weg, weg.
Warum ungültig?
Weil ich mich nicht überwinden konnte, bei einem der Möglichkeiten, die es so gibt,
einen Kreuz zu machen.
Es gab überall so viele Sachen, wo ich nicht wollte.
Ich hab einfach nichts gefunden, was passt.
Wo fährt denn der lang?
Oh, Panzer hinter uns.
Hab ich da vor uns eingesehen?
Suppresse den mal.
Falls der noch lebt, lebt der noch?
Was?
Die Rakete ist durchs Haus geflogen gerade, habt ihr das gesehen?
Die Rakete ist einfach durchs Haus geflogen.
Ich rappe.
Rapperino.
Eigentlich brauch man zwei Rapper, um ordentlich zu rappen.
Zackt.
Geaunt wurden wir.
Was ich gemacht habe, dass es ungültig ist, ich hab einfach ein paar Striche drauf gemalt,
so quer über die Seite.
Also das ist definitiv ungültig.
Da kann man nichts reininterpretieren in das, was ich da gemacht hab.
Ich glaub, die haben es ein bisschen auf A abgesehen, die Jungs.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der Typ herkommt.
Oh, meine Güte ey.
Das werd ich auch noch gemessert von hinten.
Rekt.
03D Rekt.
Achtung.
Skillshot.
Oh, das war knapp.
Das war richtig knapp.
Nochmal.
Gucken, gucken, gucken.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sportlich, den treffen zu wollen.
Aber es war knapp, oder?
Müsste relativ knapp gewesen sein.
Sag mal, was ist denn hier los?
Ich bin One-Hit.
So was von One-Hit.
Das kriegen wir vielleicht noch mal diffused.
Komm Leute, go.
Dann halt nicht.
Nice.
Jumpt ja gar keiner raus.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Könnt ihr euch an Anfang des Games noch erinnern, wo laufend Leute aus diesem Heli rausgejumpt
sind?
Oh, meine Fresse.
Ich krieg grad so krass auf den Sack.
03.
Beste Runde.
Aber ich kann mit der Map auch nix anfangen.
Normalerweise skippe ich die immer.
Mag die gar nicht.
Wo ist der denn?
What?
Erstmal eine halbe Stunde zurück rennen.
Fast Mover.
Falls ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen hab, stellt sie noch mal.
Oh, meine Güte.
Na-Aim.
Richtiges Na-Aim.
So viel Na-Aim kann man eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Jetzt räumen wir von hinten auf.
Hier müsste nämlich noch einer sein.
Der weiß nicht, wo ich bin.
Das ist auch gut so.
Hier ist keiner mehr.
Hier kann man sich immer gut drinne verstecken in den Gebäuden.
Moment Leute, diffused.
Wie sind die da überhaupt hingekommen?
Ich mach Meat Shield.
Was?
Teamwork?
So muss das sein.
Ich geh wieder rüber.
Was?
Na-Aim ist nicht zweideutig.
Was soll denn daran zweideutig sein?
Ach so, nein, nein, damit ist North America gemeint.
Wobei ich Not Available-Aim auch nicht schlecht finde.
Aber damit ist Na-Aim gemeint.
Also so, North America.
Im Gegensatz zu EU-Aim.
Wobei es bei Overwatch gerade umgedreht ist.
Nu-Szene ist so im Arsch.
Und Na-Szene ist ziemlich gut.
Ich hol dich.
Yolo, ich hol dich.
Ah, fuck.
Ich dachte ich komm noch um die Ecke.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass man das in Korea anders sagt.
Jetzt aber, diffusen.
Komm, Leute.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Fuck.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Knapp.
Richtig knapp.
CSGO ist tot, ist klar.
CSGO ist circa so tot wie Call of Duty auf der Konsole.
Also gar nicht.
Explosionssimulator.
Ich dachte das Ding explodiert.
Aber da kommt Wasser raus.
Was soll denn das?
Wassertank in 2K17.
Wassertank.
Warte, Moment.
Der Duke ist an A dran.
Move.
Das ist das Hübs-System mit Battlefield.
Ist schon krass kaputt.
Also Battlefield 3.
Jetzt komm.
Move, Ditch.
Das ist Battlefield 1.
Das ist der erste Teil, wo das Hübs-System, was hier mit Battlefield 3 angefangen haben,
gut funktioniert.
Schonmal gesagt, dass ich die Map nicht mag.
Ho, 3 zu 6.
Hui, ich bin ja gut.
Dafür haben wir schön geouten auf den anderen Maps vorher.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein paar gute Infanterieaktionen hin.
Hallo?
Geht da wieder rein?
Panzer.
Ich bleibe auf der Treppe, weil ihr wisst ja, der Panzer kann die Treppe nicht kaputt
machen.
Weil Map-Design und so.
Der Panzer ist ganz schön nervig.
Aber der Panzer ist ausgestiegen.
Da gehen wir jetzt rein.
Ich will den Panzer rein.
Gegnerpanzer.
Gegnerpanzer holen.
Go, go.
Fuck.
Okay, gehen wir rüber.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie man die Maps spielt, aber...
Ich bin echt schlecht auf der Map.
Ja, wie schlägt sich eigentlich Rainbow Six zur Zeit so?
Am Anfang relativ viel Hype gehabt, ziemlich schnell abgeflacht und dann wieder recht
große Fanbase aufgebaut.
Wie schlägt sich Rainbow Six denn gerade so?
Ich gerade einfach nur scheiße bin.
Aber die spielen alle M16, ich muss jetzt auch, glaube ich, M16 spielen.
Einfach mal OP-Waffe rausziehen.
Panzer, Panzer vor der Nase.
Panzer vor der anderen Seite.
Alter, was ist hier los?
M16 nerven, in dem Game wird nichts mehr genervt.
Next map please, next map please.
Noch mal Flank-Action.
Die haben mich aber bestimmt schon gespottet.
Hallo CheesyPro.
Finden wir hier noch ein paar Gegner.
Finden keine Gegner mehr.
Das gefällt mir gar nicht, dass hier gerade das ganze Haus um mich drum herum umfällt.
Findest du Flock Sieg, Dota 2 hat doch richtig viele Zuschauer.
Also ich glaube Spieler und Zuschauer, Dota 2 hat doch glaube ich sogar noch mehr Spieler
als CS.
Müssen wir das Steam-Status Ding gucken.
Dota 2 schlägt sich so weit, ich weiß ziemlich gut.
Was machen wir hier eigentlich?
Warum rennen wir denen entgegen?
Wollen wir uns schrecken lassen?
Es ist total bescheuert hier raus zu pushen, dann sind wir hinten und bin ich bei den Amp-Coms.
Ich hasse die Map, ich hasse die Map einfach.
Ich bin halt einfach, auch wenn ich Battlefield-Fan bin, ich bin einfach kein Fahrzeugspieler.
Guck mal jetzt sind wir hier vorne, aber gut dann ist die Map wenigstens schnell vorbei.
Die Map ist vorbei, zum Glück.
Dota 2 hat mega wenig Zuschauer, was die auf Twitch gerade mal 400k haben, also ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob 400k wirklich schlecht ist, ich gucke jetzt mal Steam-Status Ding, also
ich glaube das letzte Mal wo ich geguckt habe, hatte Dota 2 eine ganze Ecke mehr als CS.
Gerade hat Dota 2 723k und CS 606k und PUBG hat 1,4 Millionen, aber PUBG-E-Sport wird
nie ein Ding sein, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das ist ein Spiel zum Stream-Gucken und zum Selbstspielen, aber ich glaube e-Sport technisch
wird an LoL, CS, Dota und so schnell nichts rankommen.
Jetzt habe ich ihn überhaupt für Sachen ausgerüstet, ich will erstmal die Mauer kaputt machen.
Geht das nicht mit der, brauchen wir da andere Munition?
Komm, fahr!
Autsch, zurück, zurück, zurück, zurück.
Ich treffe nichts mit diesem Kack-Auto.
Größter LRV Noob-Fahrer aller Zeiten.
Was Dackel warum du gekickt wurdest, keine Ahnung, ich habe schnell gekickt.
Oh, gerade Spavnen.
Die erste Base ist auch sau schwer hier B.
So, jetzt müssen wir das aber mal bashen.
Oh, guck mal der LRV ist wieder da.
Ich kann den wieder in den Sand setzen, ich bräuchte den Zoom.
Moment, hier ist keiner da, der uns retten kann, das ist schlecht.
Dann steigen wir mal aus.
Das war aber letzter Drücker.
What the fuck?
Die werden jetzt gebashed da drinnen.
Ich kriege da vorne nichts gespottet.
Moment, was ist denn das für eine Runde gewesen?
Hallo, haben wir jetzt schon verloren oder was?
Raus hier Leute, raus.
Sobald ihr hier raus kommt, werdet ihr geschreckt.
Das wird noch was, ich sage es euch, das wird noch was.
Oh nee, die haben A, die haben A wieder, wir müssen zu A.
Die haben uns in LRV geklaut, perfekt.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, ich muss A saufen.
Was, was, game willst du mich verarschen?
Alter was ist das, wir hatten es doch, sehr fair, sehr fair, danke game, sehr fair.
Habt ihr es gesehen, was gebashed und dann einfach so muss das sein.
Richtig direkt, aber nicht direkt von den Gegnern, sondern direkt vom game.
Ich habe nur Battlefield 3 sauber, Battlefield 1 habe ich gar nicht, habe ich mir nicht
gekauft.
Da sind richtig gute Stats, ich glaube das war der, der, der Ingenieur, der mich zweimal
gebashed hat.
Hab bestimmt auch SCP gewählt, wohl, so auf A kann man scheißen, B ist das Wichtige.
Ich bleib mal hier liegen.
Fuck, Head Clitch noch ein bisschen, kommst du hier rein?
Head Clitch ist real, sowas zu sein.
Hier kommt ihr nicht durch, hier kommt ihr nicht durch.
Ok nachdem wir jetzt so viele Leute bei B sind, gehe ich auch mal ein bisschen vor.
Direkt, jaja scheiß drauf, das können die wohl schlagen.
Was, ich wollte gerade sagen M16, aber es gehört kein M16, Leute jetzt rennen sie alle
zu A, wie die größten Noobs, als hat noch einer das Game nicht gespielt.
Man kann auf A komplett scheißen auf der Map, B ist das Wichtige.
Ich hoffe die kommen jetzt nicht von der Seite, doch da kommt einer von der Seite, was, oh
man was mach ich denn gerade, ich krieg ja nichts auf die Reihe.
Tja, das hab ich gefällt, sobald der erste durch ist, ist durch, also sobald der erste
richtig durch ist, kannst du nix machen, wenn dann die Leute nachspawn, keine Chance.
Was, jetzt haben wir das gestürmt, oh ich glaub's net, das war aber ganz schön kurz
getickt.
Okay, jetzt
ordentliche defense position bb siebauer ist er rausgeflogen
moment b gut dann dann halb b
wisst ihr was battlefield 3 ist ein game wo es mich gar nicht stört großartig zu verlieren
ist eines der wenigen games wo mich das nicht stört also ist jetzt nicht so dass ich sagen
wir haben die runde verloren das stört mich nicht großartig guck hier b zu gehen war schon
wieder fail der muss gerätzt werden
der will nicht dass ich ihn treffe
die halten wir jetzt hier schon an der ecke
hauptsache in zwei in zwei bis drei medipacks stehen moment moment game an warum habe ich
konnte ich den grad nicht treffen das muss mir das game jetzt mal plausibel erklären
oh die haben gelegt die hatten die nicht schon ich dachte die hatten a schon fack oder jetzt
wird von hinten aufgeräumt jetzt wird von hinten aufgeräumt jebaited jebaited jebaited
hat aber nichts gebracht ich brauche ich brauche brauche was was ist das für ein set up was
ist das wie kann man so spielen und natürlich war noch nicht mal ein medipack perfekt das
war der richtige train der am start war gerade leider nicht so viel gebracht 1840 so muss
es sein moment schwimmt er ist er gerade geschwommen
so gerade hier ist ja gerade einer lang geschwommen das war aus wir schwimmen auch mal eine runde
recht ist hart korrekt ich bleib mal hier hier ist eine gute defenz position
die steigen jetzt gleich aus die steigen gleich aus
sie sollten gleich aussteigen weil die reppen übrigens leute die reppen und ich darf den
repper nicht treffen hallo ihr macht es schon da unten jungs nein ihr macht es nicht jetzt
aber leute die fußt da ist ja noch einer da geht rauf rauf schwimmen warum kannst du
da nicht hoch super ich dachte er kann nur mit leiter warum
konnte er da nicht hoch sowas ist in die soldaten
blurets
Oh, oh, da kommt ein Laff
Baschen
Doch nicht Baschen
Keine so gute Idee gewesen
Fuck, oh man die sind schon durch und sind schon an der M-Korps und wir hampeln hier vorne rum wie die letzten kacktubs
Ja natürlich habe ich ganz vergessen noch mal zu erwähnen
Ihr könnt das klippen und da eschen deren bastel dann ein west oft raus
Wenn ihr gute clips habt
Es gibt glaube ich auch das Kommando aus rufe zeichnen best of
Und dann weiß ich nicht mal wie man das verwendet richtig ich bin zu dumm meine eigene
Ich bin zu dumm an der eigenen bot-kommandos zu können
Ich würde gerne dieses scheiß fenster hier kaputt machen dafisch aber nicht
Yolo
Fuck! Fuck!
Boah, wenigstens noch einer erwischt.
Die wollen jetzt aber legen.
Legehänne! Auf den Weg zur Legehänne der Typ!
AMM komm!
Ein nice Legehänne.
Da ist ein LRV.
Das musste böse ausgehen gerade.
Ein Tick den ich seit Call of Duty 4 habe ist
Bei jedem Death
bei jedem Death
guck ich ins Scoreboard.
Weil
Weil geht.
Schreckt.
Mich zu sagen schreckt.
Noch mehr schreckt.
Und jetzt ist schreckt.
Ich muss wieder in das erste Stock
nicht das erste Stock
in den ersten Stock
vom Haus wo ich eben drin gewesen bin.
Das ist eine super Position um das AMM komm zu verteidigen.
Also quasi da wo
Dings hier ist. Er hier.
Bloß da oben. Gegenüber.
Gucken wir ob ich durchkomme.
Der LRV ist leer geschossen.
Nice.
Moment.
Kann das sein das über mir einfach total voll ist?
Nee?
Wo sind denn die?
Sind die neben dran oder was?
Sind die da neben dran?
Kann man das aufmachen?
Sind die hier neben dran?
Kann man da neben dran?
Ich weiß nicht wo die sind.
Da sind sie! Yeah!
Das war eine gute Position
zum verteidigen.
Ich korrigiere das.
Aber wir killen ganz gut was.
Kriegen wir das defused?
Kriegen wir das defused? Nice.
Oh da kommt ein LRV.
Was?
Wo kam das her?
Das hab ich nicht gecheckt. Wo war denn der Typ?
Stand der hier drinnen?
Oder war das Gegenüber?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht gecheckt wo die waren.
Ich versuche zu defuse.
Ich mach Mietchill.
Nice.
Rekt.
GG.
Ups, aber man darf hier nicht mal schreiben nach dem Game.
Sonst hätt ich jetzt geschrieben Eats.
Ja so wie Baro sah, würde ich sagen war jetzt nichts dabei.
War zwar eine ganz coole Runde, aber so insgesamt ist es kein Gameplay was ich verwenden würde.
Lol 3D.
Das ist das beste Emote.
Das beste Emote.
Für alle die das nicht sehen können, Bella Twitch TV installieren und dann animierte GIF Emotes einschalten.
Schau mal in den Ingame Chat.
Da muss ich über Procon schauen.
Eats.
Wie lange machst du noch?
Was haben wir denn jetzt? 16.50 Uhr?
Weiß nicht.
Solang es Bock macht.
Vielleicht bleibt ja der Server ein bisschen belebt auch wenn ich nicht drauf bin.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall cool.
Weil es gibt leider nicht viele gute Battlefield 3 Server.
Vor allem halt nicht Best of Rush Maps.
Mit einem ordentlichen Gameplay.
Und halt nicht gleich 64 Mann.
Weißt du 64 Mann Metro 247 gibt es ein paar.
Aber das finde ich halt nicht so toll.
Das ist ganz witzig für eine Stunde aber danach ist es auch gut.
Was?
Was schießt ihr auf mich?
Gar nichts.
Ich dachte ich kann jetzt hier was bashen aus dem Auto raus.
Aber nee.
Ich muss hier weg.
Von links kommen ganz viele.
Von da.
Was?
Hack.
Im Vergleich zu gestern war das wahrscheinlich kein Hack.
Sondern einfach nur gut getroffen.
Jetzt.
Ich glaube gar nicht wie wichtig in dem Game das ist.
Das war einfach zahlenmäßig ordentlich.
Einfach Numbers hat.
Da kommt er angeschlichten.
Was?
Hab ich noch gereckt.
Aber ich denke das sollten wir kriegen.
Vielleicht kriegst du sogar noch ein Rätsel.
Krieg ich noch ein Rätsel?
Nice.
In dein Gesicht.
Ein Frosch mit großen Augen.
MonkaS.
Ja das ist halt.
Ein Frosch mit großen Augen.
Das könntest du jetzt zum Beispiel posten.
Wenn ich gerade die Granate, wenn ich gerade die Rakete in die Fresse gekriegt habe.
Und knapp überlebt habe.
Bam.
Schreck.
Da fliegt er.
Und jetzt hängt er in der Luft.
Weil die Physik Engine sich gedacht hat.
Nope.
Kein Bock mehr.
Und ich werde dich so krass baschen.
Alter.
Hauptsache ich nicht.
Ach.
Was ich übrigens sehr nice finde.
Dass ich ohne großartige Ankündigungen oder sonst was.
80 plus Zuschauer habe bei diesem World Game.
Das finde ich sehr sehr nice.
Sehr sehr nice.
Und vor allem weil ich kaum gestreamt habe in den letzten 2-3 Wochen.
Der Heli Typ fuckt mich richtig.
Jetzt gibt es Trick 17.
Ich zeige euch jetzt Trick 17 falls uns der Heli nicht killt.
Passt mal auf Trick 17 jetzt.
Das machen nur die Ultra Pros.
Guckt hier. Guckt hier.
Er macht es schon. Der Sebaro hat es gelernt.
Der weiß wie es geht.
So geht das hier. So gehts.
Das machen nur die Mega.
Die Ultra Pros.
Und jetzt. Hallo. Reinspringen.
Nope.
Lull.
Moment der Typ kommt hier in der Mitte gleich hoch.
Fuck.
Blind oder was?
Ich warte bis ihr reingespawnt seid. Ich rette euch nicht.
Ich warte bis ihr reingespawnt seid.
Jolo.
Ey Leute.
Mit einer Hand gelegt und mit der anderen Hand eingekillt.
Jetzt wird aber gerade weggespray. Das muss ich mir jetzt mal speichern.
Moment ich dachte da liegt einer dran.
Das war jetzt schon eher Monka Shake würde ich sagen.
Wer will den Heli? Keiner. Keiner will den Heli.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli.
Moment warum habe ich kein Leben verloren?
Wie groß bist du eigentlich? 1,75 in dem Dreh.
Kommst du her?
Ihr dürft bei mir rein spawnen. Ich gehe euch jetzt nicht retzen.
Spawn bei mir rein.
Rechts drop rechts drop.
Versuch mal den Sibaro zu protekten während er leht.
Äh liegt.
Lege Hände macht.
Au.
Lass mal gucken was von hinten nix rankommt.
18-1 die Runde ist echt nice.
Rekt.
Erinnere mich mal nach der Runde dran das ich klippen muss. Also Shadowplay rückwirkend aufnehmen.
Wir flanken jetzt mal rum.
B geht normalerweise immer.
B ist normalerweise nicht so das Ding.
Wir gehen mal aufs Dach. Ich hab's. Ich hab's. NEIN!
Ander von der Seite. Fuck.
Scheinbar jetzt haben sie gerade anders überlegt.
22 das ist nice.
Was? Ist da einer auf dem Dach?
Adi adi spam.
Jawoll wir gehen als den Panzer.
Ich weiß nicht von wo du getroffen wurdest.
Von da oder was?
So aber eigentlich muss ich jetzt nen Panzer spawnen.
Moment der Panzer ist schon fast down.
Oh oh.
Bam.
Ich hau mal wieder ab.
Ich hol dich Kollege.
Bam.
Bam bitch.
Nochmal Bam.
Bam. Nicht Bam.
Moment warum stirbt da nicht der Panzer?
Bam.
Bam. Oh nicht Bam.
Bam. Jetzt aber.
Ich werd euch awnen Jungs. Der Panzmann ist am Start.
NA aim. Krasses NA aim.
Ich glaub ich geh mal zurück. Ich bin nämlich alleine nur noch hier.
Au au au.
Weg.
Jetzt sind wir wieder raus hier.
Krass nicht.
Komm her.
Schreck der Typ hat sich verschossen.
Moment warum stirbt der nicht?
Der hat zwei Rep-Engineers hinter sich gehabt.
Wir haben doch keine Legehände gemacht.
Wir sind quasi ungelegt.
Anstatt ungespielt sind wir ungelegt.
Danke.
Was? Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Wie oft soll ich noch um die Ecke gekillt werden?
Direkt.
Alter.
Komm jetzt.
Wo sind die Jungs eigentlich gerade?
Was zum Teufel geht hier gerade ab?
Mit dem Shotgun Typ das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt kurz nochmal an aber.
Das erscheint mir verdächtig.
Wie krass bin ich hier jetzt nicht an Absnitem?
Wir sitzen gerade ziemlich in der Falle.
Yolo.
Doch der Erx war eben noch am streamen.
Das hab ich gesehen war mir entwischt.
Und wie lief's Overwatch technisch?
Ja Shadowplay hab ich gerade gemacht.
Und wie lief's Overwatch mäßig?
Und was sagst du zur neuen Mercy?
Wie immer.
Was sagst du zur neuen Must have Mercy?
Das was ich bisher gesehen hab in Streams muss ich sagen.
Ich find's zwar generell nicht gut wenn ein Held absolut Must have ist.
Aber ich find's nicht schlecht.
Es gibt keinen AE Rätts mehr als Ultimate.
Sie hat jetzt eine Fähigkeit zum alle 30 Sekunden Rättsen.
Und wenn sie ihre Ulti hat kann sie fliegen und alle 10 Sekunden Rättsen.
Genau zum Fehler ausbügeln.
Du kreist an einer stirbt Rätts.
Also kannst du es kaum noch erlauben ohne Mercy zu rennen.
Würdest du Overwatch streamen?
War zwar nicht gut weil ich 3 Seasons nicht gespielt hab.
Aber ich hab in den letzten 2 Streams wieder ein bisschen Rank gespielt.
Placeruns haben wir gemacht und dann haben wir hochgelevelt auf 3950 oder sowas.
Ich muss mich hier verstecken.
Die scheinen mir ziemlich geil auf P zu sein.
Da muss ich mal supporten gehen.
Ich fand den Massen Rätts auch nervig.
Allerdings finde ich es jetzt gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich finde es immer blöd wenn es einen absolut Must have Held gibt.
Moment was macht denn der Typ da?
Geiler Schneiper!
Was ist mit dem los?
Okay die werden jetzt hier auf A stürmen des Todes.
Was?
Da oben war doch gerade einer hab ich doch gesehen.
Hab ich das falsch gesehen?
Nee hab ich nicht falsch gesehen.
Wusst ich doch dass da einer ist.
Hab ich doch richtig gesehen.
Ich war Panic knifen sollen.
Hast du jetzt dein Stream in 1008sp laufen lassen sollen? Warum?
Wir müssen ihn mal weiten jetzt.
Einmal durch alles schrecken.
Wir sterben jetzt die Leute.
Da oben im Haus.
Oh die legen.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh da kommen aber viele jetzt.
Wo sind denn die alle?
Ich brauche hier eine 360 Kamera.
Um mich im Kreis zu monitoren.
Dass ich alles sehen kann.
Die Jäger sind nicht schlecht.
Prenzentuchen.
Flank Max komplett.
Das war nichts.
Das war zu viel.
Der ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Der hat schon einige Stunden in Battlefield.
Ich bin gegen gute Leute.
Moment warum ist er nicht gestorben?
Wir springen jetzt raus.
Ich bin von alleine raus.
Da unten ist einer gerannt.
Ich versuche jetzt mal zu diffusen.
Das war nichts.
Das war zu viel.
Wir müssen da oben rauf.
Haben wir alles?
Mein Chat ist kaputt, ich seh nix mehr.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Battlefield 3 macht, obwohl das Game schon,
jetzt müssen wir überlegen, 2011, ne?
6 Jahre alt ist.
Unglaublich bock.
Das Game dürften ziemlich genau 6 Jahre alt sein jetzt.
Kommt einem noch gar nicht so lang vor, oder?
Überleg doch mal, 6 Jahre ist das her.
6 Jahre.
Wisst ihr was das Beste ist?
Am PC hat Battlefield 4 halb so viele Spieler wie Battlefield 1.
Obwohl das ja quasi das Aktuelle ist.
Dazwischen kam noch Hardline.
Also sprich, das vorletzte Battlefield hat halb so viele Spieler,
und wir reden hier nicht jetzt irgendwie von einer Million zu einer halben Million,
sondern von 24.000 zu 12.000 Spieler heute Morgen gehabt auf dem PC.
Und Battlefield 3 sogar hat heute Morgen, glaub ich, 3.000.
Also, wenn man einen günstigen Tag abpasst,
haben wahrscheinlich Battlefield 3 und 4 zusammen auf dem PC,
oder wenn es so weitergeht mit Battlefield 1,
haben sogar Battlefield 3 und 4 zusammen irgendwann mal mehr als Battlefield 1.
Wir zahlen für Hardline 2.
Ich glaube, wenn wir 1 nicht sehen, dann ist es Hardline 2.
Es wird mal Zeit für Bad Company 3.
Dafür wird's mal Zeit.
Für Bad Company 3, und dann nicht so ein Fake Bad Company 3,
also nicht so nach dem Motto,
wir machen Bad Company 3, weil die Fans sich das wünschen, und wir mögen unsere Fans,
und wir lieben unsere Fans, und ihr kennt ja das ganze Geschwätze immer,
sondern in Bad Company 3, was wirklich Bad Company 3 ist.
Wie hat der mich nicht gekillt jetzt?
Entschuldigt, nein, entschuldigt nicht, das macht CBA auch schon.
Hier, in the pack.
Achtung!
Nein, der hat sich doch anders überlegt.
Ist der Typ down?
Ich geh da jetzt vor.
Also nach allen taktischen Sachen ist jetzt die beste Variante vorzupuschen.
Siehst du, das ist das, was ich vorhin gemeint hab,
aber nicht lange fackeln.
Bäm, eingekillt, es sieht so aus, als sind wir gerade mehr Leute da,
als ist gerade überlegene Situation für uns drauf.
Und das trifft einfach auf alle Games zu, auf alle Multiplayer Games.
Man muss wissen, wann man defensiv bleibt, und man muss wissen, wann man angreift.
Und vielleicht unviel man Granaten wirft, denn so wirft man keine Granaten.
Achtung, komm, komm rum, komm rum.
Wat?
Hopp.
Stimmt, die 1070 Ti kommt bald raus.
Wo platziert die sich eigentlich?
Ich mein, wir haben eine 1070, wir haben eine 1080 und wir haben eine 1080 Ti.
Wo platziert sich die 1070 Ti zwischen 1070 und 1080?
Weil da ist ja nicht mehr so viel Platz dazwischen.
So, jetzt können wir rein.
Wie exklusiv, ja.
Mal ein Switch exklusiv.
Let's train.
Hallo, ich darf nicht schätzen.
Und jetzt würde ich gern hier rein hüpfen.
Ich würde gern hier rein springen.
Yolo, da drüben sind ganz schön viele Gegner.
Jetzt hätte ich noch einer gerannt, klar?
Bam, best.
Vor dem Auto habe ich Schiss.
Auch reckt.
Den holen wir schnell.
Den holen wir uns jetzt.
Wo ist der Typ hin? Einer müsste hier noch leben.
Tja, Kollege, so nicht.
8-0, so magisch das.
Ja, lauft an mir vorbei, lauft an mir vorbei.
Dann auch nicht euch von der Seite.
Kommt her.
Oder auch nicht.
Äh, keiner da?
Warum?
So hardcorrect.
Oh, alles tot.
Jetzt muss ich auch mal Shadow Planen.
1 KS.
Der, okay, der ist.
Flup. Lass mich mitfahren.
Lass mich mitfahren.
Okay, lass mich doch nicht mitfahren.
Oh fuck.
Was stehen die denn da noch rum?
Moment, da kommt von links jetzt gleich was.
Da oben war was.
Wie die sich grad außen lassen.
Ist ja Wahnsinn.
Oh, ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Was denn das?
Das war ne hässliche Waffe.
Ich muss hier weg.
Was ist das für ne hässliche Waffe?
Ja, ich hab mir das richtig angemüht mit dem Rekt.
Sei froh, dass ich Rekt sage und nicht Eats.
Ich kann auch zu jedem Kill sagen, easy.
Grip 15-0. Ja, gleich mal Shadow Planen.
Au, au, au, au.
Oh, hier ist grad ein bisschen viel los.
Komm her.
Hallo?
Jetzt wird reingecharged.
Yolo.
Oh fuck, wär das geil gewesen die zwei noch von der Seite weg zu sprayen.
Vielleicht krieg ich ja noch nen Rettz.
Rettz-Blitz.
Nice, nice.
Was macht der Typ da unten eigentlich?
Ich fahr mit.
Oh, OPM Track.
Richtig nice.
Den wollen wir bashen.
Ich seh nix.
Joa.
Das Duell lasse ich mich gerne ein.
Alter, fährst du hin?
Okay, ich steig aus.
In den Amtrak können die eh nicht einsteigen.
Können die eh nicht einsteigen.
Na?
Der hier ist doch so dunkel.
Das Aim mit dem Ding.
Das bringt ja nix.
Also, wenn du mit dem Ding gut aims.
Die Dinger haben halt ne relativ lange Flugzeit.
Das ist halt das geile an dem Defi hier, dass das dir auch quasi die Tode nicht zählt.
Uh, aber schön getradet, schön getradet, vielleicht krieg ich schon ein Rätsel.
Krieg ich schon ein Rätsel? Krieg ich schon ein Rätsel?
Danke.
Oh, fuck.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Das war's mit der Attacke.
Moment, was geht hier gerade?
Moment, wir sind hier noch.
Wir sind noch dabei.
Ach, sie bauen uns und spawnen schon mal bei dir.
Geht weg.
Ich muss den Typ ownen, der uns von der Seite bashen will.
Ich kann den Schnitt retten.
Rekt.
Jawoll.
Oder nee, easy soll ich jetzt ja sagen.
Hab ich ja ganz vergessen, easy.
Easy kill, easy kill.
Too easy, too easy, oh fuck.
Das war auch too easy für den Pop, für den Pfünder.
Der Pfünder hat mich wieder gepfünd.
Alle in der Ecke hinter der Wand bei dir.
Oh.
Okay.
Dann machen wir jetzt Flag-Action, klar.
Was?
Hä?
Ach, der Sebaro ist verreckend, immerhin, wo ich gespawnen bin.
Ich kann sagen, wie kann das sein?
Und auch Legehände machen, schöne Legehände.
Schöne Legehände machen.
So gefällt mir das.
Richtig nice Legehände.
Ich rette euch.
Oh, was ein Pech.
Ich hab gedacht, auf die Entfernung können wir noch aus der Hüfte sprayen, wegen besserer
Mobilität.
Oh, Clap ist nicht enabled?
Das muss ich nachholen.
Das muss ich nachholen, True Elmo.
Clap ist das Wichtigste.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, von wo ich beschossen werde, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist mir gerade zu hoch.
900 EQ-Plays.
Wie kommt man hier überhaupt drauf?
Da.
Oh, nice.
Ich bin noch nie, noch nie hier lang gefahren mit dem Boot, noch nie.
Da, da hinten, haben sie wohl vergessen, die Map weiter zu mappen.
Ich sieht schon keiner.
Oh, oh, da guckt, von links guckt da einer, fuck.
Also, mir war klar, dass links einer steht, aber auf den Fight hatte ich eh keine Chance
zu gewinnen.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich renn einfach.
Ich dachte, ich renn einfach, in der Hoffnung der Typ trifft mich richtig.
Weil, wenn ich stehen bleibe und versuch ihm zu one on one, klappt das garantiert nicht.
Langusta, Tangusta, Tangusta, Tangusta, wie immer das Ding genau heißt.
Piss dich, Alde.
Oh man, dachte ich mir hier, richtig leise ein Plays rausholen.
Was geht hier eigentlich ab?
Wo ist der Typ?
Da, weißte.
Wenigstens einer wäscht noch.
Ja, das ist aber keine Capture würdige Runde mehr.
Er kann es ja nix machen gerade.
Rättsplitz.
Nope.
Gibt's nicht.
Kein Rätts.
Was haben wir überhaupt für Perks?
Ja, das passt.
Heli gegen die Luft abwehr ist wahrscheinlich nicht so optimal.
Ah, go go, linke Seite, linke Seite pushen.
Wir brauchen da Leute vorne.
Besten suppressen.
Was?
Was geht mit dem Typ ab?
Ja, lass mich rein spawnen, lass mich rein spawnen.
Rätts.
Danke.
Fuck.
Was ist hier los gerade?
Hier geht ja nix.
11-7 sieht nach Hacker aus, ja.
Was?
Was ist denn hier los?
Hier geht ja gar nix.
Meine Fresse.
Danke.
Ich muss mal nachladen.
Okay, jetzt werdet ihr gebashed.
Der Hardcore Bash ist real.
Und jetzt Attacke an Biran.
So geht das, so macht man's.
So macht man's.
Aua.
Verpiss dich mit deinem Kack, Chef.
Du siehst mich nicht.
Aua.
Luft abwehr.
Ich hab Schiss.
Hopp, das war nix.
Nein, spring, spring.
Das Hüpfsystem ist so kaputt.
Das kriegen wir jetzt.
Kriegen wir jetzt.
Aua, na.
Und?
Einfach mal irgendwie sieben Kills oder so.
Fuck, einer hat's überlebt.
Kommt, Leute.
Ein, ein, einer noch.
Ich retze, ich retze.
Fuck.
Scheiße.
Aua, wie knapp.
Wie knapp.
Aber wir haben das ja von Taimou gelernt.
Gewinnen ist nichts.
Verlieren ist alles.
Weil nur verlieren bringt einem infinite knowledge.
Deswegen, es ist gut, dass wir verloren haben.
Infinite knowledge.
Habt ihr eigentlich mitgekriegt, dass Seagull Envy gejoint ist?
So, mal an die, die Overwatch ranked verfolgen.
Ranked?
Was erzähl ich denn?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ranked.
Streich das ranked.
Die, die Overwatch Pro Szene verfolgen.
Da bin ich ja richtig gehyped drauf.
Seagull Envyas, nice.
Die brauchen guten Genji-Player.
Genji-Fahrer ist alles nicht so das, wo Taimou und Effekt jetzt gerade scheinen.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, dass die hauptsächliche Idee dahinter war, sie haben jetzt ja, also
Envy hat ja massig Investment gekriegt an Kohle.
Die wollten einfach so mit den bekanntesten Overwatch-Player eben bei sich haben.
Ich seh mal ein Fadenkreuz nicht, ne.
Sonst würd ich den treffen, aber ich treff ihn nicht, weil ich mein Fadenkreuz nicht
seh.
Bam.
Nobody in Real life left because of 100k.
됐으.
Aber ja, zeig mal deinen Bruder.
Klack, klack.
1-0-0-0
1-0-0-0-0
Ja Leute, schnappt euch mal den Heli
Schnappt euch den Heli Leute
Ich bin kein Heliflieger, ich sucke damit
Ich schnapp mir den Heli nicht
Aber ich flieg mit
Ne, ich flieg nicht mit
Oh da kommt
Amtrak
Ein richtig nice Amtrak
Jetzt steigen sie aus
Und werden gebashed von mir
Next please
Oh
Das ist letzte oder vorletzte Runde
Oh, ouch
Ups, ups
Wie lang stream ich eigentlich schon?
Drei Stunden gleich
Ich dachte, er wollte den Shroud machen
Ne, ne
Siegel ist richtig gut
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum da immer so drüber gelacht wird
So nach dem LOL Siegel und sonst was
Wenn man sich Streams von ihm angeschaut hat
Der spielt schon richtig gut
Marcel, du solltest lieber
Weitere Kanzlerkandidaten interviewen
Anstatt mich hier zu snipen
Wo geht hier überhaupt was?
Pick nicht mehr durch
Das hier zur Defenden ist sau schwer
Echt schwer
Haha
In den Arsch
Geschreckt
Oh, da war einer
Ich hab's gesehen
Hopp, du wolltest den retzen
Los
What the fuck
Ich weiß, dass ihr wisst, dass ich
Dass ich da bin
Fuck
Ich kann sie outmoven
Was?
Ich bin mit dem Ding in meiner gesamten
Battlefield 3 Laufbahn vielleicht 5 Minuten gefahren
Wie funktioniert das?
Was macht man damit?
Man macht damit Damage
Stell dich gerade fest
Der Magischief macht das
Oh, da steht ein Amtrak direkt vor meiner Nase
Nicht so gut
Die wollen mich abschießen
So was aber auch
Da kommt was
Ich weiß nicht, wo der ist
Schau mal ab
Rep dich mal
Kann das irgendwas?
Hat das ein Zoom oder eine Sekundärwaffe oder irgendwas?
Moment, hinter mir ist was
Das kann das Ding irgendwas
Shoot
We Sebastien
Lull
Anstrengend anstrengende sache outplayed so sehe ich das auch elbow outplayed
Da werden sie geklatscht
Kleinen
Jetzt hat es aber ein bisschen viel
Go go go auf spavnen
Wurde gerätzt
Ich muss hier weg ich muss hier weg flenke flenke 900 IQ play
Das hätte so gut funktionieren können
Wieviel IQ hat man eigentlich wenn man 900 IQ players ausführt aber sie nicht klappen
Spawn go go
Spawnen
Ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin rennen soll
Na na so viel na aim
Jetzt aber
Der shown ist da 잰
Fakt von hinten
ist da
von hinten
das ist dann
ja das ist aber
da ist
mal eine mausintelligenter hier
das ist wahrscheinlich sowas was
eine Ameise hat
hallo
oh
bin ich gestackt
achten wir jetzt hier
ohne flank
fuck
ich sollte mal ein bisschen defensiver stehen
ja
hi joe hawks77
fuck man
wir werden
übelst gereckt
ich muss weg
fuck fuck fuck
komm
streck den kopf raus
wo sind die außen
das sind viel zu viele
was geht da unten drinnen ab
kann mir das mal einer erklären
der boy himself
ist am start
ja
trade
kack trade
ja
kriegen wir das noch defended
kriegen wir das noch ordentlich defended
oh wie voll
wie voll es da ist
fuck
ne da geht grad nichts
aber immerhin einer wäscht noch
oh nice
kriegen wir das
wir haben das noch defended
glaubt nicht
ja
sehr schön
so gefällt mir das
schöne flank
ich hör da links
ein auto
ach das ist unseres
ah fuck den wollte ich grad retzen
auf
wie keine augen fürs mcom hat
schon geil
ah fuck
ah wir haben es noch
hüpf hüpf hüpf
rauf
es wird echt eng
die sind ganz schön am vorpuschen
pusherino
oh
da werd ich geschneibt
ich guck lieber mal von hinten
dass da keiner kommt
an das steinzeug mal weg
fuck
hätte ich lieber hinter
meiner box gehockt
der macht jetzt noch legehennen
macht er nicht
macht er keine legehennen mehr
fuck sind alle down
ich sag euch die legen noch
oh wie knapp
äh wen ich gewählt habe
ich hab ungültig gewählt
ich hab große
große striche und gedöns
und kreuze und sonst was auf den zettel gemacht
dass man das nicht als irgendwas interpretieren kann
ich konnte mich einfach nicht
überwinden bei einem der
möglichkeiten die es da gegeben hat
mein kreuz zu machen
es gab bei jedem was wo ich gesagt hab das will ich nicht
ja mit absicht
ich guck mal kurz
wegen essen und ob ich noch ne runde mach
ich bin gleich wieder da
so
so eine runde mach ich noch
eine runde mach ich noch dann wird nochmal gegrillt
so zum abschluss
des sommers
piss dich elevi
wird man bei ungültig auch als nichtwähler gewährt
ne wird man nicht
das ist ja grad der witz dann hätte ich auch daheim bleiben
können wenn es als
nichtwählen zählt
ich wollte damit eigentlich die aussage treffen
alles sagt
mit wem grillst du
ich grille mit 2 grills
von einem typ
und mir
oh guck mal da steht ein panzer rum
rekt
moment ich retz dich
ich retz dich
retz 360
das ist das neue meta in dem game
piss dich
schnell retzen und umdrehen
hab ich die geowned
hab ich die krass geowned
die haben auf den sack gekriegt gerade
aber richtig
uuuh
der chat soll plötzlich auf die dk auf das boot zu schießen
wat
wwpd
tipps zu real life sport an
ist klar weil ich so der krasse real life sportler bin
ne
also wenn ich zu einer sache
definitiv keine tips geben
kann dann endet es in irgendwelchen sport an
schieß keiner sonst mehr drauf
wat
a
das glaubst du doch selbst nicht kollege
dass das funktioniert
a a a a
wa
was war denn das
der boi himself war das
ja squash spielen
aber das was ich da an squash spiele das kannst du nicht mal wirklich als squash spielen bezeichnen
das ist zwei leute mit nem tennisschläger
stehen von der wand in einer squashhalle
und beide haben keine ahnung wo man squash richtig spielt
das was wir da machen
das kannst du das geht noch nicht mal
als squash spielen durch
der typ geht aber ab
ich hatte mal gute
ausdauer aber aktuell hab ich nicht
wirklich gute ausdauer
doch ich
ja was heißt dick
also
wenn man jetzt die auswahl hat zwischen dünn und
dick dann bin ich eindeutig eher dick als
dünn
zumal es e-videos gibt
wo man mich schon gesehen hat
zumindest genug
davon gesehen um das einschätzen zu
können
der boi
himself mit dem stimmt was nicht
der boi himself trifft
mal ein bisschen gut
ich schicke euch keine
ich schicke euch keine videos
da müsst ihr schon selbst rausfinden
das ist auch grad der witz daran
einfach mal das ein unter die nase reibt das ist ja langweilig
am besten fand ich es bei der ersten gamescom wo ich gewesen bin
da haben sie uns auf der leinwand gezeigt
im activation stand
und irgendeiner der leute der da auch war
hat es halt mitgekriegt
also von der leinwand gemacht
hat es auf twitter gepostet
und ich habe einfach nicht drauf reagiert
und es hat keine sau gesehen
das fand ich auch geil
keiner mitgekriegt
was machen die da vorne eigentlich
haben die nichts besseres zu tun
als da vorne auf dem felsen zu sitzen
ja
ich werde euch jetzt bashen
ich werde euch das richtig krass
bashen
so wurde ihr noch nie
gebashed
oh wir haben es
nice
ja in der lage was zu treffen ist doch echt schwierig
boho
fahr einfach rechts rum
fahr doch einfach rechts rum
mit dem ding trifft man über distanz jetzt nicht so gut
was machst du die ganze zeit
hast du so wenig zeit für youtube hast
ich streame
ab und zu
und dann halt auch relativ lange am stück
und youtube als plattform
geht mir einfach auf den sack
ich hab irgendwie grad keinen bock auf youtube
achtung hier
jetzt wieder gebashed
nice
beste position hier
mit dem lhv
bessere position kann man gar nicht haben
du musst hier wegfahren
sonst sind wir im arsch
gegen zwei panzer kann man mit dem amtrak nichts machen
fahr rechts rum
fahr doch rechts rum
ja in dem da gab es mich auch zu sehen
ich hab mal ein bier gerade
ich hab gerade mal ein bier festgehalten
stimmt
das amtrak hatte auch ein mg
da
das hätte ich jetzt voll vergessen
stimmt
das amtrak hatte auch ein mg
jetzt wo du sagst
ja das hat er überlebt
vier burst in den kopf easy
ich werde meinen channel nie dicht machen warum sollte ich das machen
ich werde immer ab und zu was hochladen
und manchmal auch
auch viel je nachdem
ich darf gerade nichts mehr treffen
es ist gerade die night
treffen die night
hau
ich bin aber gerade on
echt scharf auf mich
heißt es zufällig in real life max feepis
nein
der boy himself
da trifft ganz schön gut
auf
schleicht sich drunter durch
was
das stimmt doch was nicht
ich meine das sind alles kills die sind möglich
ja
aber
das war schon verdächtig
gerade
ja
das ist gut
ich hoffe nämlich, dass auch während ich da nicht drauf bin
vielleicht ein bisschen was drauf gespielt wird
weil das regelset ist super
einfach die besten classic
crush maps
nicht so viele tickets
nicht so viele slots
das ding steht in frankfurt
also sprich
gibt auch
auch ordentlich anbindung
was
wer bitte getroffen
hau
super
Ohohohoh
Wie er über den Gegner drüber gesprungen ist
Achtung
Ne, ne Leute, ne
Das glaub ich net, das glaube ich net
Schau dir mal die Stats von dem Typ an, da stimmt was nicht, ich guck jetzt auch mal schnell.
Hier kommt man das nachgucken.
Ja, mach das, mach das mal, guck dir das mal an, da stimmt was nicht.
Der Boy himself.
Das kann letztens sein, aber die Treffer waren schon echt, echt, manchmal sehr, sehr...
... am Rande des Möglichen.
Okay, Leute, das war's, ich muss jetzt grillen gehen.
Nee, nicht, gleich geht's los.
Wo ist meine Endcard? Ich muss jetzt grillen gehen.
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Und ich hoffe wir sehen uns das nächste Mal.
Macht's gut, bis denn, tschüss.
Das war's für heute, bis dahin, tschüss.
Tschüss, tschüss.